President Trump making final
preparations for tomorrow night's State
of the Union address this is the
president refuses to budge on getting
money for the border wall ahead of
another possible shutdown would you shut
down the government again well we're
gonna have to see what happens on
February 15th you're not I don't I don't
take anything off the table I don't like
to take things off the table
it's that alternative it's national
emergency you need a wall and anybody
that says you don't they're just playing
games Nancy Pelosi will be seated
directly behind Trump tonight and that's
not stopping the president from blasting
the House Speaker over her resistance to
the wall she knows that you need a
barrier she knows that we need border
security she wanted to win a political
point I happen to think it's very bad
politics because basically she wants
open borders she doesn't mind human
trafficking or she wouldn't do this
so Emily what are your expectations for
tomorrow night State of the Union and
how do you think Nancy Pelosi will
behave behind the president I hope that
she keeps an you know impassive face
obviously for at least the decorum of
holding that position my expectations
are you know I think is it's it's I will
say I would not be surprised if in it he
called on that emergency declaration if
he referenced it and basically said
again look this is what I'll do
you're predicting the state of emergency
declaration tomorrow night no I don't
know I don't wanna be held to that but I
just think you know the more that I've
looked into it it's it's such a viable
option and in in large part just bird's
eye view because one of the reasons for
emergency powers is because of the
ineptitude and inability of the
government to get it done legislatively
or not in it or not in a timely fashion
that's exactly what we need right now so
unless something drastic happens on the
other side which I don't see because
everyone's still playing semantics with
wall or barrier or whatever then what
other option do we have
all right one you're gonna be down in
the swamp tomorrow night well don't tell
Mitch McConnell about your idea because
I think the Republicans are pretty clear
to president trunk don't do it but yeah
I don't think he's gonna do it tomorrow
in any case I think tomorrow is really
from what the White House is saying much
more about trying to
exhibit the capacity to reach out to
Democrats and say here are things that
we can get done the five points that
they put out so far include things like
infrastructure like you know what hey
both sides we can work on this we can
get something done right and so he wants
to I think especially in the aftermath
of the declining poll numbers that were
caused by the shutdown Fiasco say hey
listen I am trying to work with these
Democrats they're the ones that aren't
doing right and put the pressure on the
Democrats so that's what he'll try to do
the Democrats for their part they're
bringing to illegal immigrants who are
working for Trump to sit in the audience
the mahkum know okay so what's Trump
gonna call ice the president has usually
gotten rave reviews for the State of the
Union addresses from the mainstream
media did the Democrats run any risks
you know sitting on their hands yes when
he talks about all the great things
economically they're happy so I think
there's a high chance so you'll have
some heckling or some sort of highly
staged walkout hmm by Democrats I think
the president Trump will keep us cool
and maybe make a little joke about it
and he'll you know win the hearts and
minds back at home I think that when he
is praising troops or certainly talking
about the economy and job numbers and
unemployment rates imagine the camera
shot then of Senators Harris Warren
Gillibrand Booker there's congresswoman
Tulsi Gabbard I don't know whoever else
is running for president and if they're
sitting boot face you know looking like
they're unhappy that's not gonna be
necessarily good for them but you know
that they have a choice to make right
now because they have to see if they can
stand out from one another I also think
the two big bipartisan pieces tomorrow
night will be infrastructure once again
around that loop but Pelosi and Trump
have actually talked that they could
agree on that but the other big one is
going to be prescription drugs and some
sort of a plan to deal with the high
cost of prescription drugs it is not a
conservative position but it is one that
you could get bipartisan agreement was
last week infrastructure week every week
every week is infrastructure right so
Gregg you're not gonna be down there no
I'm not may god I'm gonna be here mine
in the store I'll be I could be at the
news deck just a you know do my thing
yeah yeah yeah this is incredibly
tedious this event
I think they should split into two and
let maroon5 play in the intermission you
could serve some of your case oh no I
finally figured out how we can build the
wall your case oh you know where that
stuff hardship you know what with this
thing though though the so - yes is it's
time to take stock of the presidency but
it's hard to take stock of this
presidency cuz all the sound and fury in
the last two years it's like impossible
to sit back and go hmm
this cacophony doesn't really match the
deeds when you think about the weave you
subtract the polarizing business model
of the media you have jobs economy
military optimism North Korea trade
prison reform all this neat stuff that
basically when you take a look at it the
left the left should love this guy he's
walking around the planet reducing our
military footprint I mean if you look at
North Korea tulsi gabbard should be
thanking him Syria whether you're
against it or not he's this very
left-wing Afghanistan Yemen I mean you
can disagree with all this but the steps
being taken
I mean he's moving away from conflicts
shouldn't have left be embracing this
that's everything the left said that
they were about long and now you're
against it just because Donald Trump is
for it because it's because the Intel
people said hey you know what they're
still there and still trying to kill it
you can have two competing thoughts in
your head
I said don't want one of the kids is
destroying Isis the other one is
continue to say that the headline to me
was the President did sum up his
presidency he said it's he's the best
president ever over those last 10 an
understatement I might